Well,
I never really thought of the media was
some kind of bullying.
Something has changed.
I mean the media now is so diverse and
so complex and there's so much of it,
you know,
you can find problems with
anything I suppose,
but the fact of the matter is a lot of
media today isn't targeted to me a
reason to target with any person in
particular.
They look for certain market segments
and they go for them and they really
don't care anything about anybody else
or what anybody else thinks.
And uh,
you know,
professionally I was part of that
process for a long time.
But I do believe today if you're an
active,
involved,
educated,
thoughtful person,
you can find a mix of media that appeals
to you,
satisfies you more readily and better
than any point in time in history.
So you can say,
oh my God,
the media,
they're so exploitative.
They lean towards a sensational thing or
they don't have enough international
news coverage.
But you know,
it's your decision what you want to
watch.
And there's just so many other options.
I really have a hard time feeling sorry
for anybody who has that point of view.